hi it's his girlfriend um i'll i look
forward to meeting you at the gym um
yeah it'll be great to see you and make
sure you wear those leggings can you
order me a pair too i'll send you some
cash send me your details see you soon
bye
[Music]
welcome to relationship goals i'm theo
johnson your host and i'm with a12funny
this guy is gonna be the judge jewelry
and executioner relationship goals is a
tournament where coppers go head to head
to see who's got the most solid couple
if they win this they go to the
semi-final if they win at the semi-final
they go to the final and if they win the
final
show
even all this money you know
but more importantly as my judges
demonstrated they win 100 free firewave
pizzas
and whoever wins just know about me and
them was friends from time to go i'm
saying there's hope
i'm going to try blowing in the trash
anyway let's go my name's hans i'm jana
and i'm here to test him out yeah we've
been in a relationship for eight months
she just doesn't trust me
it's the things that you do but
you do you have trust issues a little
bit but with me is him it's what he does
we're always blamed for things like this
as black men you know is your partner
the one
tomorrow my name is emily and i'm here
to do a
question quiz with my partner my name is
teo i'm here for exactly the same thing
oh we've been together like six months
now just over six months
i don't have any idea what to expect
from today
are you guys ready don't be shy man it's
all right man you like looking like
relationship goals still i got i got a
good feeling about today i feel like
today is going to be a good day mm-hmm
it's going to be a good day not a long
day it's going to be a good day so
ladies if you kindly go to the
soundproof room because the guys are
going to predict
what you guys would say
[Music]
so guys for question one
i'd like to know
if your girl was in jail what would the
crime be
and i'm gonna ask tail first
she's outspoken in it oh no it's
probably says satan while probably
someone was like yo chill
she probably didn't chill
probably just threw inside there to be
honest she said she got a bit violent so
you're saying gbh then grievous bodily
harm there you go so gbh would you want
to just put manslaughter oh
okay yeah
what do you think your girl would be in
for
well i would say first of all she's got
anger issues so like i would say she
might have caught a body store like i'm
not gonna lie no
see
are you sleeping with one eye open then
basically
one time
when i'm sleeping
one day
[Music]
really
is that how you feeling you're a brave
man though you're a brave man you like
you like them fiery girls isn't
question two if your girl was in jail
how long would you wait before you know
you have to
you know you have to do your thing
basically i'm gonna ask harm first this
time to be honest like she's my girl and
i love her so i would actually wait a
long time
but like when that month is done
i respect you i respect it me personally
i'd wait forever you get me obviously
i'd ride that with my girl you got me
something's burning back there was that
i'm just smiling a whole load of
[ __ ]
just write the damn answers
um
i'm a loyal
so uh if i jump into a relationship
obviously like i made a commitment for
that so i'll ride out as much as long as
possible i'll give it about five months
are you being serious i'm giving about
five wait how long have you been
together been together for seven months
okay so
that's fair because it's like seven
months five how long have you been eight
months okay all right i can see why it's
not like they've been the other ten
years
five months it's still a long time
good overall five months something all
right five months so this question won't
be hard either then out of your girls
friends which one would she say you're
the monster you you think's peng
she's got a friend called shannon
you didn't even hesitate she's sweet in
it i'm saying but i'll see
with that millionaire so
kind of condensate what does that mean i
want to explore that what does that mean
are you trying to say that because she
got there first no i'm saying obviously
what guy isn't it so you know we see a
girl that's pretty we acknowledge it but
obviously i'm with emily in it but
how do you acknowledge it so so
i'm not trying to stick on me
have you made it clear though
because it sounds like this is deeper
than normally people would say but you
kind of i feel like there's something
there like you've made it known have you
kind of like have you ever made it you
know deeper literally ah man i told you
i'm loyal in it all right say no i'm
saying we won't push any further
i'm not gonna lie there's one on her
instagram store she took a picture she's
taking a couple pictures of her store
just like like you said you checked
quickly
what's her name
i don't even know her name but like that
he was pre and that hard bro mandy even
look at the username i'm just looking at
three blacks
wow you know when you get the picture
and you zoom
[Laughter]
she's always trying to like you know
catch me lacking so i just gotta look
quick i'm not looking at the name i'll
just see maybe yeah i need a name bro i
need a name so we can write it down
we'll just call that bondalicious
that's not gonna get answered for that
bro oh yeah
[Music]
all right ladies
someone bring the ladies from the
soundproof room please we need you back
he's already screaming loyalty when he
wasn't
so for question one we asked your
boyfriends you guys was in jail
what would it be for
what do you think that i'm gonna go
with
oh jana first well i did yeah so i asked
your boyfriend if your girlfriend was in
jail what do you think it would be for
for
fighting
so like gbh
that dance you want to go for yeah i'm
not even that i don't
[Music]
emily yeah
oh my god so that life was like i've
already been in jail yeah
five times
um okay so i'm like quite outspoken
i'm like very um passionate
and
i can get myself into trouble for trying
to like just seek justice i swear it
might have like wrongfully been put in
jail like a rosa parks thing exactly
stand for your rights
at the black lives matter protest like
you saw me yes but i think he would have
said something like maybe sticking up
for him maybe like i beat someone down
oh defending his honor yeah defended his
arm you cast that as like as a criminal
act it would have been full murder if it
was like
whoa whoa
so you think he would have said murder
then no
maybe let's just do gbh ubh yeah cbh
i'm gonna log that in yeah okay
the questions have been answered and
you emily was actually i'm sorry correct
was that it was correct well that's
you actually said the exact same thing
he was at
obviously
is outspoken and that forget me
the synergy's there man well done used
to
well he was like yo i'm not going to
live with i'm sorry couple man down and
i think personally it would be a fat
still i'll be coco m's as well she'll
probably be on the run for five weeks
for four buddies
that's what she said that's what he said
on it yeah basically so he's talking
about murder and you came on and was
like i'm like mad innocent i'm so calm
but that's how the murderer is like i'm
mad innocent you know what i mean like i
wouldn't never either
[Laughter]
what no i didn't yeah yeah yeah that's
what i thought i'd fire you away
[Laughter]
so yeah you got the answer wrong i for
some reason like the jail theme so i
kept it in jail and i asked your
partners
how long would they wait
for you while you ride that bird
i'm gonna go with
oh jenna first how long do you think
holmes would wait he wouldn't wait ah
what you don't wait would you wait wait
you can't ask you can't ask you have to
answer to me
so you would say what zero days
i think you're trying to check it out
you try for like a week a week and then
just so you're going with are you going
to go with a week so one week two weeks
what
one week okay cool
one week and
that says this
so emily i'll ask again
if you was riding that bird for being
doing at rosa parks how long would
taylor wait for you i don't think he
would wait long because he's a beautiful
man okay
[Music]
i would hope that his sisters might be
able to like
encourage him to kind of do the right
thing or whatever because obviously i'm
only in jail for him okay so
i'm gonna go with like realistically
maybe a couple months
but what's a couple like i need
specifics all right cool let me say like
three months three months yeah
you wanna lock that in
all right cool
so the answers are in and
both of yous are sick because both
viewers got it wrong
i love doing that i started running back
you know wait can you tell me how long
he is yeah oh sorry he said five months
you're right okay good job
he said one more he said a strong
month he said it would be hard though
yeah so question three we asked your
boyfriend which one of your friends does
he thinks peng
she's about to catch a number
it's okay it's only a game show all
right
i'm going to ask her jenna first because
she seems more composed
um i'm just going to say
i see you look at her
so you're gonna lock tiana okay all
right that's what we're gonna do okay
wait wait wait let's explore this i see
you look at her yeah cause i heard that
as well so what's the thought process
little wayne told me when i was younger
yeah he said real g's move in silence
like lasagna oh yeah forget what i'm
saying so she's looking and seeing what
if she speaks about it when the murder
happens that's evidence it's heavy
that's not evidence that's heavy
evidence
do you get what i'm saying
so that's why she's just seeing
not speaking so when the blood's leaking
no one's preaching
with nearly almost almost
are you composed i'm fine yeah so what
my god when they say they're fine
fine they're not fine
what do you think tails said
i think he said can i not say her name
because when she watches it i don't want
her to get like oh
you're going to have to say her name i'm
sorry
so you want to lock that what's what's
her what's her name
no he knows who i mean i don't know we
don't know who you mean we don't know
pardon sharon
oh swear so her name's sharon yeah
okay
i never really got it right because the
way his head is hanging yeah we have to
go to the var for emily's answer
he said shannon
no it's sharon so he pronounced it wrong
then so when he's so is that oh wait do
you have a friend called shannon no just
to be sure that's what he said right
yeah he definitely said shannon right
okay so is shannon sharon l is sharon
not shannon no you know shannon in it
wait wait
shannon that you wanna yeah
yeah i'll see you
wanna c on instagram oh so there is a
shannon
there's a shannon and there's a sharon
but sharon challenge is the cool girl in
it sharon's my best friend oh she's just
a cool girl but [ __ ] that girl shannon
though shannon's got that milk is that
what you're saying i'm just i'm just
trying to understand what your
boyfriend's saying about shannon no
disrespect emily sharon is the cool one
that's her best friend exactly okay so
you would have just fell out with that
one oh so i'm surprised that he would
mention her name oh you just found out
we're on camera
oh to say she's playing it's just a bit
weird but you fell out with shannon yeah
but like madly shannon kind of a [ __ ]
that's that premeditated murder and
sound effect
yeah it's just it's fine
shannon obviously i know you just fell
out with emily but a man thinks you're
buffing it yeah
this is what it is what um
i was just um yeah yeah so oh jenna
you
you got that woman's intuition still you
got that answer correct correct no cat
yeah no capronius but i don't know how
happy you want to be about it because
that means you're right in thinking that
your man be watching your bedroom and
he'd be thinking forward i see it i do
see it
i love you you're lacking bro
when you're sleeping
yeah there's a strategy you know what
you're walking down the road are you
would you go and the girl walks faster
you exactly you gotta
so when the girl walks past you just
spam you solid with it you just keep it
walking even though you wanna you just
have to
get what i'm saying we're on different i
was looking i was that oh you was
looking
oh no i don't look bro you know you
gotta be loyal out here man shout out my
girlfriend
anyway yeah yeah yeah for round one in
episode three
the score is officially
oyena and harms so you have one
and
emily
and teo
won you know
when you need to wait it's a bit tight
but now the mandem are gonna go into the
soundproof room and we're gonna ask the
women some questions you know that's
what i'm saying
all right so before we carry on and we
get into it with these women i mean what
whoa i've got a girlfriend okay i've got
a girlfriend
i didn't anyway yeah before we continue
the show the game show i'm loyal
subscribe
like comment that's all we want you to
do shout out standout tv subscribe like
and comment for the first question i'm
gonna ask you something kind of personal
could hurt your boyfriend's feelings if
you had to change one thing about your
boyfriend what would it be you go first
his height
oh
the speed
oh my god no but i didn't finish
the question like she was no
she
like you saying both crying
oh
that was not an old jenna that was the
shortest answer part of the pun that was
the shortest answer
he's high oh
you did it again
oh she does it every time
anyway
emily
his love of football
just because it's like i can't really
connect with him on that do you feel
like he puts football before he doesn't
put it before me but he loves it do you
think he loves you or do you think he
loves football more than he loves you
i think football's been
a more consistent in his life and been
around for longer so i'm okay with him
loving football more than me at this
stage
what i would do is i would do some sort
of role play okay you could dress up as
ronaldo in the bedroom and jump out of
the closet
naked and shout
i'll try it i'll try it yeah let us know
how that
let us know how long that match lasts
love love of football okay change that
sorry we've got iron man
and you'll we know you you
oh
hi she said that so aggressively family
all right cool
all right so question two if you and
your
other half broke up let's say it was
finished it was done
what man
would he say use that would go back to
so i want to know secretly why nothing
what guy do you have there
on reserve you know let's keep it
football what guy is the substitute on
the sidelines what guy is the the garlic
bread to your nandos is what i'm asking
so i'm gonna go with all jenna first
because emily's shaking her head like
she's not willing to give up the truth
yeah she was she's laughing already yeah
you already know he made her laugh you
know she thought about him
he just makes my clitoris flutter
look at her getting red blood
oh no your boyfriend is over there
that's what i'm saying like
come on okay cool
only because like
oh here we go just fine
we said it wasn't gonna be a long day
you see friends
it doesn't mean friends where they're
from let's talk about this
friend right now oh yes right now yes
right now hey
were you for
date mm-hmm also
use today
also your good friend good friends you
see when you say good friends is kind of
your friends the wood friends
the friends is it the kind of friend
that you're like on the sofa watching
netflix no
so it's not like [ __ ]
huh
football match oh
what's his name oh yeah you have to say
the name
and she wait she said six oh no
i'm hearing she likes football she likes
tall guys if i don't last after this
show here honey no no no no no no no no
no
no
no
no
don't lie
i will send you the details i don't know
what wait i don't know what's happening
but something's happening
i was about to say she called him d he's
a friend and he saved in her phone as d
and she likes to play
football with thee
like it just doesn't get any more bait
the math is nothing
fam if you broke up with your boyfriend
yeah
what guy would he say you'd get back
with or get with he knows full well i'm
like very like
not stubborn but like
i know i know where i'm going and i'm
going forward not back
so for that reason i believe he would
say my son's dad just because there
would be a reason for me to go back in
society's eyes
maybe it'd be fun
i'm gonna write that with accents so
question three what
did your boyfriend tell you
his body count was
and i'm going to go with emily seeing as
her eyes oh my god blew out her face he
actually said he doesn't
know
well he said that's amazing if he was a
porn star
wow he said less than 20. so you're
saying that your boyfriend wait wait
wait i don't know he wouldn't so your
boyfriend how old is he why did i say
that okay 26. okay so he went to school
yeah here we go he got his gcses he done
universities i don't care i'm gonna push
on it no but he don't know how to count
to 20.
so you're saying below 20.
is the lie he told i mean is the thing
it's the thing he told you to ask me i
would be like well you're hot and it's
like so
i'd say like let's say 150. but he said
less than 20. that answer yeah less than
20. yeah okay cool you know what i do
respect though i respect the like
attraction you've got for your man we
haven't seen that on this show yet
really some people just like be hating
on their man's heights
so i respect it i respect it a lot what
did your man tell you his body count was
the thing is
he wouldn't he didn't say it because
he's a christian man who shouldn't wait
for their wives when they're in jail
are you saying that he's waiting till
marriage yeah so he's a virgin
even with you is that virgin or virgin
media zero yeah e so you're yeah okay
i respect that
bro wow the dishonesty i mean
the answer yes sorry
that was really good i think that you
like really know your boyfriend so the
men are back so whilst user was away
enjoying pizza we asked you guys some
interesting questions and they had even
more interesting
answers
it was very interesting i feel like used
that i loved a lot by your other after i
respect it so with that being said i'm
going to say that we did ask them what's
the one thing they would change like
this small thing and you know how some
people like see if i asked you what's
the one thing you change about your girl
you know you'd have to think about it
like you know how it would take a while
from drawing up lives like you'd start
thinking like
her hair follicles
she answered before i finished the
question sir so
we're going to do some role play you're
going to play oh yeah now i'm going to
play me
what would you like to change
that's that's what happened
okay so what do you think the blah was
maybe my attitude that person attitude
well you think you're a bit rude in that
yeah
maybe i can be she says but i don't
think i'm rude i just feel like if you
want to say something would you say like
you have little man's syndrome like nah
well i think you might have
mispronounced you said attitude the
answer was actually altitude because you
said heights
i know how cool are you though
i said the munchkin you know
you're gonna have to talk about it at
home so we asked emily what's the one
thing she'll change about you
what do you think that was sir i want to
say attitude but i feel like
i'm very committed very loyal so i won't
say that i spend time with her but i
think that maybe she probably want me to
spend a bit more time with her
can you elaborate on that um
i don't know i'm always busy busy doing
what
is he playing football okay all right so
how would you sum that answer up oh no
sorry just want me to spend a bit more
time with her
it's interesting that one so the judges
we're gonna go to the var so as you know
a1 is the judge
you said spending more time because
you're always out playing football and
stuff your girlfriend i can now reveal
said your love of football she would
like to change the love of football
because you don't spend enough time with
her so it's there but not worried i
didn't say it the way i said it in the
okay but it was a lot of information
that was so okay why did the va say all
right yeah all the medieval authorities
as well sorry sorry uh yeah i'm speaking
to the team you know i'm a nice guy i'm
also i'm six foot five so uh since we're
of the same league seems like there's a
bias here uh seams on the same league um
and you to be honest i asked you to
elaborate and the final point of the
actual statement was spend more time
because you spent too much time playing
football and that answer was love
basically the love of football and yeah
i'll give you that that's fair
[Music]
don't worry bro don't worry about it bro
no it's all good down here it's about
tory lanez it's calm down that's what
i'm saying it's calm all right it's all
right bro don't worry about it man it's
calm bro
[Laughter]
round two question two
i asked if god forbid of course use that
broke up
who
would they go back to um
one of them i'm not going to say no
names oh yeah was giggling and going red
and laughing about this but i'm not
going to say any names oh yeah no but um
what do you think emily
said
hey no yeah
did she mention a guy called michael
who is michael because michael sounds
like it he's got a deep voice like yo
michael sounds like he's got like twenty
foot dreadlocks you know what's weird
when he said michael he sounded five
foot did you see how he went shorter
when he said
michael must be seven
is that michael yeah
like someone was squeezing yes anyway
let's get back to it who's who's this
michael tale michael was the guy that
she was saying
before she was seeing me it wasn't
anything serious but do you feel like
there's still something there nah man
she's loyal she's low okay the respect
the loyal is there yeah like i trust
that she's trustworthy but like i would
say probably like her ex what's his name
that's the thing she hasn't i've always
asked his name but she always keeps the
name there can you describe this x for
me yeah describing this unless you say
he's like
young
dark male
she's got probably got braids twisted as
well okay okay so she's got a type yeah
look i look like my copy that can i ask
are these two
still
friends are these people
friends oh that's the word you're still
friends with hmm wait you don't know no
no obviously she's told me no but whoa
seventeen and a half seconds ago was
that obviously that man trust her render
and i gave
i need some elaboration so you're saying
he's not best friends now but he didn't
know you was friends at all so what does
that say for your relationship i feel
like there's a breakdown of
communication here i say hi and bye oh
so you don't you say hi and buy it oh
cause i thought you would go to football
matches and stuff but i don't know why i
don't
know anything about [ __ ] i thought
you were playing tig and tag and stuff
right yeah tennis
you know she said
d
she said she likes going to football
matches with this guy but he's just
a friend i can now confirm emily said
her baby father
she actually said she don't feel
interested in her baby father like she
don't care about a baby father but she
thought you might think
the only guy she would go for is that
baby father because he's kind of the
only person still around who still has
access to our yard at late nights when
you're not there and his son's there so
he can be there any time he needs to for
his son see the way you're doing that
stuff
by the way
to be as a judge i do have to be very
specific it wasn't just baby beer before
though yeah she added a little pepper
i tried to help you and i said to you
elaborate like what does this ex do
cause if you just said yeah she's always
going football matches with the ex i
could have done a var yeah
i gave you that i gave you the short man
assist but you didn't you know what i'm
saying you couldn't reach it
anyway
that was a low blow question it went
over his head
he went over his head
sorry
[Laughter]
[Music]
well i'm taller than your man anyways
i'm so there's so much dick swinging in
here above yo just relax everybody just
relax
i asked these ladies
what did your boyfriend tell you his
body count was um what did what was your
boyfriend harms
what did you tell oh jenna your body
count was
man's using his fingers you know you
know what you don't have to see when you
see with them fingers are you doing are
you doing the cross for jesus christ
seven seven seven was that seven deadly
sins
seven
seven deadly pumbles
so oyana did say that you was a and she
was a virgin
are you not a man of god i don't know
who lied um but i don't know who told me
so you just chose to just get that
answer wrong for freedom basically you
that don't wanna wait
you're forgetting what's on the line
somewhere in the 20s i want to say 21
21
say 21.
is this what you told her or is this
what your your thing is
listen i might really tell her that i
had to jump in it you know what i'm
saying okay
do you know your number yeah wait he
just said man told her say what you told
me
i told her two in it right right at the
beginning okay obviously that was a lie
until i came clean
clean and then told her the truth and
told her it was
about 20 21
somewhere around it all right so less
than 21 we're gonna go with the answer
give me a clear
in one
phrasal word what's your answer
that was less than twenty the computer
says no i sexed him so now it's 20. you
sext him wow look at that jim sexton the
results are in there's a lot wrong on
your side i'm not gonna lie it's not
looking pretty for you guys stairs is
windy and yours is wind with a bit of
with a hint of sun you know what i mean
impossible rainbow after the rain
okay so that makes the overall school
for round one and two two
to emily and tail
and one
to oh jenna so you start going
through round two as the leaders so
they've got one more point you don't
think about it
for round three we're going to do
something interesting i'm gonna need you
zlat to find your phones and then switch
phones
yes
yes specifically i know what you
specifically said we do remember but no
one cares what you're specifically doing
because this is relationship goals and
you're on this show to show
that you are the most solid couple
so we need to do a tiny little free
question experiment using our phones to
see who here is the most
solid
couple so everyone unlock their phones
and pass it to their partners please you
can say no by the way if you're not
happy with you need to ask why
no no no you know what no i'm not gonna
allow this double standard okay
no no no it's all right you don't no you
can't reach remember now it is actually
beneficial for you you can't reach
this is beneficial
[Laughter]
right now right
that's disrespectful
okay so at any time you can start say no
i don't feel comfortable with this
that's fine but you won't get the point
and you guys need the points to get the
money
unlock and swap
unlock and swap together
of all what i want you to do i want you
to go to
whatsapp
to the whatsapp conversation
and i want you to find
the baby father yes i was about to say
that oh i don't have him on there we're
going to go to text let's go to texas
and go to d let's type in d and see if d
is there donnie d
what do you have is that
dad she calls him daddy
oh
no wait send him a text now
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait come
let's let's let's be civil here let's be
mature we have to respect their privacy
disrespectfully let's go into daddy i
mean these um
if you have any conversations oh so the
conversation has been deleted
interesting very interesting all right
could we go into the conversation of his
ex please let's see what you see there
am i saying i said all right hold on hey
listen listen you don't need to see all
of that you get no
she's reading that are you really
scrolling like that
can you see is there anything
everything's called past egg
everything's yeah if it's good
might want to type in sharon or shannon
no
shoot no definitely not yeah but yeah
look at his ex's conversation let's just
make sure everything's cool
wait wait wait don't lock the phone wait
what's going on why can't i not scroll
is that okay
why are you scrolling for her let her
scroll bro
inflation over here yeah
no gas lighting
do everything
you know
tense boys
how come you're pinching their legs
i don't even know where i should look to
be honest there's a lot going on really
a lot of a lot of things you're not
happy with i mean i don't know i'd have
to do some further investigations oh
jesus can we say some names like what
what names are you not unfamiliar with
i'm confused about sarah's presence
sarah
so who's sarah when she's at home teo
what i think he renamed her as pizza
sarah that's a
is there anyone else
oh
no oh my god yo hold on when you're all
showing her and i don't worry about that
boy why are you worrying about herself
dude i mean
when's the last time he spoke to this
body i don't want to click it
i don't know i'm just scared i'm going
to see it
no what did you see do you want me to
click on it for you pass me the phone
yeah we'll click on it
gracie
who he spoke to yesterday oh
you were ready to make out on the bus
i will actually call her right now
i was teasing i'm shy
stimulated sorry hold on wait wait wait
wait
emotion of damage
hey
hold on a minute hold on a minute
[Music]
gonna wear his favorite leggings
oh
oh oh
oh
somebody call the cops please because i
i'm scared for everyone's safety
holloway is right in the corner just put
me straight there
um okay so now we're gonna go to the
instagram for the final
final test so for question two we're
gonna go to the instagram please
so could we go to each other's
instagrams and make sure everything's
cool pathetic there could you give could
you give her your phone for the
instagram please
if you want to i know
no no no no yeah i got a good start
you know when someone just gets a
shovel
and then you start digging is there
anything in the dms
oh everything good over yourself okay um
i'll slow down you was like passing like
that yeah no no because i read them i
read it oh so you guys are you guys are
you guys are fine yeah all right okay
use that past this round
okay
um is everything good in your dms over
um in loyalsville
i don't know what's this what's
[Music]
can i just say what i'm doing right just
so you get a picture of how
messed this is i'm not even scrolling
i'm just opening one seeing what it
gives me in that one bit doing the next
one
i'm not even scrolling like so he's been
mad wild
deontay wilder
ah
the snap that's what he's been doing
rice krispies all in that pump um
it's his girlfriend i'll
look forward to meeting you at the gym
um yeah it'll be great to see you and
make sure you wear those leggings can
you order me a pair too i'll send you
some cash some of your details
long
day
long decade oh that you should you know
look elsewhere for another six foot five
dark handsome man with braids don't
plain i am yeah don't point at me and
you're nigerian as well
oh you're nigerian my brother you know
hey run this game you know my god why
don't you just say this one is not
hey that's my guy you know
who one to the nine what
are you twins or so what's going on i'm
like you said that though
anyway respect man because you're
keeping it loyal in these streets
why
um i'll just say tail you're feeling
this with flying colors man i've never
seen something like this this is amazing
we're gonna we're gonna leave it there
we're not even gonna go to the third and
final question of round three because
we've concluded that from question one
and two
we feel like after some delegation that
tell you it's only gonna get worse from
here tail is fully disqualified from
this round he has failed with flying
quality the altitude
up here the flying colors is green white
green and you know what i just feel like
he's failed here but he's been for the
safety
for the safety of all of us and so we
don't have to call the police i'm just
gonna end the show now um just like the
relationship i've just ended so
that's been relationship goals guys and
we have our winners
oh jenna and harms who will be coming
back to the semi-final that's the
relationship goes it can get long and
that's why the saying is
long day
long decade
[Music]
yeah we lost he lost he lost so we can
just go home i can go my way he can go
his way i don't care we just why not get
up okay
are you surprised to talk about what
happened
i'm mad surprised i'm mad surprised
maybe we can talk it out and see
see what happens from here but
a bit rocky in the beginning like just
because of like miscommunication but
like in the end like the true test is
obviously if you can give over your
just be loyal and
and be in a relationship or be single
and be
frivolous you know when you find a good
person man or woman because that other
couple was shaky as
if we didn't do that loyalty test we
definitely wouldn't be leaving not quite
as lucky as them though also
his phone was looking mad still yeah i i
was crazy pictures imagine i just wonder
you know i mean like you can do your
thing freely you don't have to hurt
people in the process
you're gonna go all the way
yeah yeah
my regret coming on the show is spending
the petrol money to get here
um sitting next to him for longer than
he deserves me next to him
um
just like
yeah
what part of each other do you think he
would be most attracted to
these are looking like they're looking
at each other
this is a bit awkward i thought you was
looking through context that was all
guys
oh yeah yeah we got a lot to talk about
later don't worry about it that can't
drive philippe
[Music]
you